in this video I want to begin our
discussion of translation which is the
last part of the central dogma where we
turn mRNA into proteins before we can
discuss the details of it we need to
consider the genetic code its features
and characteristics so I've written the
six thing that I want to talk about here
it is the genetic code is a triplet code
that is non-overlapping and comma lists
it's nearly universal it's also
degenerate and unambiguous so what all
these things mean we start off this idea
of a triplet code the triplet code
simply says that each codon is three
nucleotide bases long so here we have an
example a u G so this actually codes for
Metheny and we'll talk about why later
but it's three bases that make up a
codon now why does it need to be a
triplet well because a doublet wouldn't
be enough if we had combinations of just
two nucleotide bases at a time we would
have 16 total possible combinations and
I've actually written them all out here
now 16 is less than 20 well why does
that matter right who cares
where did that 20 come from the 20 is
the idea that we have 20 amino acids so
in this case the whole purpose of this
genetic code is to have codons that code
for amino acid that we're going to
implement to make a peptide chain so if
we have 16 different possible codons
that would be less than 20 so we don't
even have enough codons there's not
enough codons for all 20 amino acids so
the next smallest codon would be a
triplet one and why does that work well
because that that leads us to 64
possible combinations which is greater
than 20 amino acids so in that case we
do have enough codons for all 20 amino
acids in addition the genetic code is
also non-overlapping so here I've drawn
an example of a code that is overlapping
and when that is non-overlapping what's
going on in each in this first one there
are three nucleotide bases that are read
as a codon the next codon is not the
next three nucleotide bases instead we
only shift over one base and read the
next of the three codons that are
consisting there so we don't read it as
1 2 3 and then 1 2 3 we read it as 1 2 3
and then this to now becomes a 1 2 3
this is not how it works in the genetic
code we it is not overlapping instead we
just read as 1 2 3 in the next are 1 2 3
each of these 3 is a codon this does
this codon just the way the codons are
right here there's no overlapping so
this is actually what happens with a
genetic code in addition it is common
list so up here I've drawn an example of
it with commas and here it's comma less
so commas you know kind of look like
this right when in sentences a separator
that can be using sentences anyway the
point is here that if you read a codon
if you read 1 2 3 codons if there were
commas the next the next base would not
be part of a codon it would just be a
comma in between the next codon so here
we'd have a codon comma codon comma 3 3
bases megacode on another comma this is
not how it works with the genetic code
there are no commas so each base there
just read sequentially 1 2 3
that's a codon the next 3 that's a codon
the next 3 that's a codon this is how it
works in the genetic code genetic code
is also universal and nearly universal
the reason that's there is because
almost all organisms use this same
genetic code there are a few exceptions
so now these two ideas of degenerate and
unambiguous I put stars next to them
initially and that's because they can
kind of give fuel trouble so degenerate
is this idea that each amino acid each
amino acid can be coded for by more than
one codon so what am I getting at there
well here's an example that may be
helpful if we're looking at ISO leucine
isoleucine can have these three
different codons
it can be a u u a UC or a UA so let me
actually show you what I mean there if
you look at this table if this is our
codon first second and third base so we
just that we had leucine so leucine or
should we not leucine isoleucine sorry
so isoleucine could be a u u a UC or a
UA all three of these codons code for
the same amino acid that idea is that
it's degenerate so here we have
isoleucine can be a you you a you see a
UA so if you have a u u it will always
be isoleucine if you have a you see it
will always be isoleucine a ua it will
always be isoleucine but if you have
isoleucine you don't know if it's
necessarily a uu a UC or a UA which this
idea kind of goes hand-in-hand with the
idea of the code being unambiguous which
basically is that each codon can only
ever code for one amino acid so an
example here is that if we do have a you
see a you see will be isoleucine or
excuse me will always be isoleucine and
it will never be anything else if so if
you look at the table here
if you have a you see that's going to be
isoleucine for sure there's nothing else
that it can be if you have a Yugi that
will always be math I mean never
anything else so if you go to the table
Aug that's Matheny it's never going to
be anything else but degeneracy if I
tell you that you have isoleucine what's
the codon isoleucine well you don't
really know right it could be a uu a UC
or a UA
that's the idea behind it being
degenerate so the V code is degenerate
but unambiguous if you know the code on
you know the amino acid but just because
you know the amino acid doesn't mean
you're necessarily another coat on
that's the idea between these two
something else I do want to mention is
that there's one start codon that one
start codon is Aug and that Aug codes
for the mid the amino acid methionine
there are three stop codons and those
three stop codons are you a a UGA and
you a G how do I remember this it's a
little bit of a silly way but if you
think about somebody if you everyone has
like a friend or a little brother or
sister or cousin or anybody that
sometimes is annoying so when people are
annoying you want them to stop right so
you will tell them you are annoying you
eh-eh you go away you tell them to go
away and eventually if they do go away
you are gone so you a a UGA you AG
simple silly but it's an easy way to
remember it I hope that video was
helpful and understanding what's going
on with the genetic code one last thing
I am a tutor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me via
email at movi University at gmail.com
see the description below for more
details thank you for watching